on a appris en ce vendredi un accident
absolument effroyable la nation est en
deuil
il y a eu un accident entre un camion et
un car il ya eu plus de quarante morts
c'est pas la première fois que ça arrive
en france simplement on sent que
l'émotion aujourd'hui elle est de plus
en plus forte sur ce sur ce drame qui
est arrivé en france
bien sûr c'est un accident qui ne s'est
pas la première fois mais c'est quand
même un accident exceptionnel d'une
telle gravité je crois qu'il faut
remonter à plus 30 ans l'accident de
moan
donc on ne connaît pas encore
précisément les circonstances de
l'accident et les raisons pour
lesquelles les deux véhicules se sont
embrasés immédiatement quand ils se sont
entrechoquées mais évidemment à ce
moment là toutes nos pensées vont aux
familles des victimes et on s'incline
devant avec solidarité et je pense que
la nation toute entière évidemment
solidaire dont cet instant de ces
familles et il faut adresser tout de
suite aussi des mots de solidarité à
toutes les personnels de secours les
pompiers les médecins les policiers qui
sont sur place et qui font le meilleur
pour essayer de deux d'éclaircir
d'élucider les raisons de ce drame
l'heure n'est pas du tout en question
n'est certain dpt comme noël mamère qui
vient de gironde souligné le fait
qu'avec la loi macron il y aurait de
plus en plus d'autocar sur les routes
est ce qui est on peut se dire qu'il ya
aussi une question peut-être
d'infrastructures c'est avec un
transport routier est dangereux et
singulièrement le transport routier de
marchandises et je crois que ça fera
probablement des parties des questions
qu'il faudra à nouveau posée on devrait
on a les moyens de réduire le transport
routier par marchandise on profite du
fret ferroviaire est malheureusement en
france comme en europe ont fait
exactement le contraire tout c'est
toutes ces dernières années en mettant
de plus en plus de camions je suis
moi-même en ile-de-france très
préoccupés des risques d'accident leyrit
ensuite bien sûr la circulation
excessive de
deux camions de marchandises sur les
routes est accidentogène et et c'est un
sujet de préoccupation mais il faut
avant de refuser toutes ces questions
d'abord mon s'incliner devant les
victimes de l'accident bien d'antan